[Music]
before you see big star turned dad
vlogger will smooth just and a friend
reunite with big star turn Big Momma
Martin Lawrence
revisit Michael Bay's answer to the
question can you make two movies out of
one reggae song chorus what you gonna do
when we come for you and that's the best
enough is next miss knows me hey no the
bad boys bienvenidos army where the but
field days turned a bud field nights and
meet Mike and Marcus too bad boy cops
dressed like they're signed to Bad Boy
Records
Marcus is a family man with a sad wiener
oh sorry you ain't getting none at home
Theresa his wound is fine it's other
things that were affected oh we saw
still flaccid while Mike only became a
cop to hide the fact he's a serial
killer
I actually prefer Sookie shooting them
from 30 yards while they running away
not that's not in point-blank I'm close
in person that's what I'm talking about
yeah run the print hey Mike stop playin
man
these partners will do anything for each
other but don't for a second think
they'll do it in a gay way I thought
maybe there are pictures of your lover
oh cool you get it cuz they're not gay
yo Mike why don't you just give it a
little kiss so they feel better get it
I really appreciate no that's not gay
get it it still hurts from what you did
to it tonight get it
a bunch of men hugging and kissing fart
joke
Rocco's gonna kill me but M&M aren't
alone they'll be joined by their captain
a walking countdown clock
we got 72 hours we got four days the
deal goes down in four hours that means
you guys got two hours to find him plus
classic Michael Bay female characters
like wife baby ballbuster I told you to
play by the rules
secretary threatened with revenge porn
pot therapist who has sex with her
patients favored prostitute underaged
Megan Fox and uh big booby corpse is a
rule these movies age like a Michael
Vick Jersey get ready for an adventure
that thinks the only way to stop crime
is way I'm doing illegal favor for you
happens to be highly illegal
I don't think gotta weigh in illegally
you got to put a word to it it was like
secret and lately and these killer cops
will use every michael bay's em in the
book to get it done like circle shots
just got real sweat military worship
form a delta that intel and demo
requesting permission to tag along
racism i kill again f-bombs I don't know
what you're talking about yes you do now
let the gun talking about you body bomb
balls
and the assumption that you're a [ __ ]
with the attention span of a
nine-year-old bar joke you fought so
strap it in for the movies that made
Will Smith into an action comedy
superstar what are you a cop or model
and make Martin Lawrence the guy stuck
next to people trying to become action
comedy superstars that elevate it to
sitcom actors in a way that couldn't
even be done today because who from TV
could even do this now fleabag and young
Sheldon
aquafina and Ed O'Neill come on just
drop the old guys again but no Michael
Bay this time last time last time fart
joke Oh
starring nor tail Miami e de baba yaga
anchor middle management drug bring it
on phony Montana two sets of actors
playing essentially the same characters
crazy snitch Haitians Grand Wizard
we got alright I don't know Joker was in
this I'm a stand-up comedian and I suck
[Applause]
Wow Wow
Michael Bay casting women that's why you
got the job cuz you look good in a
bathing suit Michael Bay directing women
kitty kitty stretched running Michael
Bay directing action and people are
putting extra stank on Mike's name's
Mike Lauer
Larry Michael a 3-mile I'm Mike Lowrey
Mike Larry you want it Mike Larry you
got him
bleeped old weapon okay someone throwing
a gun at a landmine which explodes
allowing another guy to headshot the bad
guy who lands on another landmine which
explodes - me Michael Bay's Mona Lisa he
breaks into people's houses and eats all
their beans toss a coin to your Witcher
ovalle Oh plenty
O'Malley Oh plenty it's time for death
battle feet feet feet feet feet feet
feet feet feet fede fede fede fede fede
fede be feet feet feet